[Music]
glad you're here
Orville is with us in Amarillo Texas
hi Oroville how are you hey Dave I'm
doing well how are you today
better than I deserve what's up a single
male I just found out about you and I
dove into your podcast and I downloaded
every dollar and I get paid them all and
I'm ready to get financial piece and hit
the ball roll in here but um I want to
go back to school and I'm trying to
figure out where this where that fits in
with all this I'm making twenty four
thousand right now before taxes and
that's not where I want to be okay how
much debt do you have eight thousand on
one that is with a car some medical
bills and a personal loan for 1,500
gotcha and you're working 40 hours a
week yes sir looks I'm good for you how
old are you I'm 24 24 all right and do
you have a degree now nothing past high
school okay you said back to school so I
didn't know what that meant
yeah I apologize did you start did you
ever start college um I had tried to get
started a while back with FAFSA but it
ran into some problems with w-2 issues
so had held off on it okay and just
never got back to it don't you okay what
do you want to study I'm gonna get my
EMT paramedic okay how long does that
take and what does it cost it's going to
be a four-year class the the basic in
the intermediate the first year of it I
can do locally at one of the the
ambulance stations and it's going to
cost me about 1500 for for all that and
then the next three years I haven't
priced it out yet okay all right and you
can do all of that while working yes
what are you doing now I'm a meter
reader for the city okay cool all right
well the good news is you're you don't
have a ton of
and the education you're talking about
is not super expensive at least the part
you figured out okay right so 1500 plus
8,000 so like $10,000 changes your life
yeah does that make sense
I mean your get there debt-free and got
the first two years of EMT for 10 grand
did I do that math right just the first
year okay so 1,500 for the first year
1500 for the second right yeah okay so
it's ten five okay three thousand and
eight thousand $11,000 $11,000 okay okay
it does it does make sure out of debt
and does the first two years okay so
what we need to do is figure out how we
get $11,000 the fastest possible way
right yeah and then that gets you able
to do both the good news is you can
deliver pizzas four nights a week and
make 1,500 a month in ten months
you are debt free and have the money to
do the EMT and that that's just what
getting a second Doug exactly
maybe maybe pizzas aren't your thing
okay I don't care what it is right but
my point is $1,000 a month for 11 months
changes your life and you live on your
day job yeah or cut into your day job
and start doing your budget and but make
more and spend less and let's get this
10 $11,000 together really quick this is
very doable within 12 months you would
be dead Larry you'd be debt-free and
have the money to do your EMT thing and
the good news is you could probably go
and start the EMT thing and while you're
doing this right I mean how many nights
a week is that loaded up it was three
nights every week for three months okay
for the for the first semester and it'll
be the same thing for the intermediate
yeah so what I just took away from you
was your social life that's fine I mean
that you know cuz you're gonna give up
something to hit these goals yeah the
problem is the problem with goals is not
what you're willing to do to get to the
goals it's what you're willing to give
up to get to the goals
that's what always that's what always
messes you up I mean it's easy to lose
weight but you got to give up chocolate
chip cookies you know it's easy to you
know I'm saying there's something you
got to give up that's harder than the
goat then the things you have to do to
hit your goals so all you gotta do is
start doing the math like I'm laying it
out and I think you're gonna have a I
need you to have a very successful
career as an EMT thank you sir
and you're gonna get there in about
twelve months from today you're gonna be
well into your first year but go just go
work your butt off man you're 24 you got
lots of energy that's good
and just tell your friends I'll see you
near